welcome back everyone this is part three
in our series on Advanced behavioral
testing for nlu our focus is the
principle of compositionality this is a
principle that is important to me as a
linguistic semanticist and it's also
arguably a prerequisite for
understanding the goals of cogs and
recogns which are compositional
generalization benchmarks
let's start with an informal statement
of the compositionality principle it
says the meaning of a phrase is a
function of the meanings of its
immediate syntactic constituents and the
way they are combined
that's the principle let's unpack it by
way of an example I have a simple
syntactic structure here a full sentence
every student admired the idea
and the compositionality principle says
that the meaning of this S node for
sentence here is fully determined by the
meaning of its two constituent Parts NP
and VP
and you can see that this implies a
recursive process so what is the meaning
for the NP well that is fully determined
by the meanings of this debt for
determiner node and this n for noun
phrase or for noun node
and the meanings of those are easy to
see those are fully determined by their
parts which there's just one part for
each and those are lexical items and
that's where this recursive process
grounds out the intuition is that you
just have to learn all the lexical items
of the languages that you speak having
done that and having figured out how
they combine with each other you have a
recursive process that allows you to
combine things in new ways and
understand novel combinations of these
elements but compositionality is saying
that you have guarantee there because
the meaning of the whole will be a
function of the meaning of the parts and
how they are combined we could also
think about this in a kind of bottom-up
fashion we start with those lexical
items their meanings are stipulated or
learned and memorized and then those
meanings in turn determine the meanings
of these parent nodes here
which in turn determine the meanings of
the complex nodes above them and so
forth until we have derived bottom up a
meaning for the entire sentence
why do linguists tend to adhere to the
compositionality principle well this can
be a little bit hard to reconstruct but
I would say that the usual motivations
are as follows first we might just hope
that as semanticists trying to study
language we would model all the
meaningful units of the language and
that would imply that we have gone all
the way down to even the most incidental
looking lexical items and given them
meanings in isolation like good
lexicographers might feel they should do
in practice I should point out that that
means there's a lot of abstraction
around linguistic semantics because it
is just hard perhaps impossible to give
a meaning for a word like every in
isolation from the things that it
combines with and so what happens in
practice actually is that the meanings
assigned are functions so what we're
saying here is that every is a
functional meaning that when combined
with the meaning for student delivers
another function that when combined with
the meaning of this verb phrase finally
gives us a meeting for this S Note up
here and it's something like Universal
quantification where in this case if
something is a student then it has the
property of admiring the idea that would
be the fundamental claim of the sentence
and you can see there that that claim
was kind of driven by every down there
in this determiner position inside the
subject
so a great deal of abstraction but that
is a technique for giving meanings to
all the meaningful units which would be
a consequence of adhering to
compositionality
you often hear linguists talk about the
supposed infinite capacity that humans
have for dealing with language I grant
that there is some sense in which this
is true because there seems to be no
principle bound on the complexity or
length of the sentences that we can
understand in a kind of abstract way
but this needs to be heavily qualified I
am sad to report that we are all finite
beings and therefore there is only a
finite capacity in all of us to make and
understand language and so this is a
little bit overblown but I see what this
is getting and I think the fundamental
intuition is something more like
creativity we have an impressive ability
to be creative with Language by and
large the sentences that you produce
today and the sentences that you
interpreted today had never been
encountered before in all of human
history most sentences are like that and
yet nonetheless we are able to instantly
and effortlessly produce these sentences
and understand what they mean and that
does imply that there is some kind of
capacity in us for making use of a
finite resource say the lexical items
combining them in new ways in order to
be creative with language and
compositionality could be seen as an
explanation for that
there's also a related idea from
cognitive science called systematicity
which I think is a slightly more General
notion than compositionality and may be
a more correct characterization let's
dive into that a little bit under the
heading of compositionality or
systematicity
the systematicity idea traces as far as
I know to Fodor and pilishin they say
what we mean when we say that linguistic
capacities are systematic is that the
ability to produce or understand some
sentences is intrinsically connected to
the ability to produce or understand
certain other ones
so the idea is that if you understand
the sentence Sandy loves the puppy then
just by that very fact you also
understand the puppy love Sandy and if
you recognize that there is a certain
distributional Affinity between the
turtle and the puppy you can also
instantly and effortlessly understand
the turtle loves the puppy the puppy
loves the turtle the turtle loves Sandy
and so forth and so on you get this
instant explosion in the number of
things that you know in some sense as a
consequence of your own understanding of
language being so systematic
and I do think that compositionality
could be a particular way of explaining
what we observe about the systematicity
of the human capacity for language but I
think systematicity is arguably more
General you can see that it's given a
kind of distributional characterization
here that might allow for things that
are not strictly compositional but
nonetheless importantly systematic
systematicity is a powerful idea for
thinking about the intuition behind many
of the behavioral tests that we run
especially the hypothesis-driven
challenge tests that we run because very
often when we express concerns about
systems they are concerns that are
grounded in a certain lack of
systematicity and here's a brief example
to illustrate this this is from a real
sentiment classification model that I
developed that I thought was pretty good
and I started posing little challenge
problems to it and I was initially very
encouraged by these examples
the bakery sells a mean apple pie is
generally a positive Claim about this
bakery's pies and it involves this very
unusual sense of mean which essentially
means good a mean apple pie is typically
a good one
and I was encouraged that the Gold Label
and the predicted label aligned here
similarly for they sell a mean apple pie
I was happy to see this alignment and I
started to think that my model truly
understand this very specialized sense
of the adjective mean
but that kind of fell apart with the
next two examples she sells a mean apple
pie he sells a mean apple pie both of
those were predicted negative whereas
the Gold Label is of course still
positive
the errors are worrisome but the deeper
thing that I was worried about is the
lack of systematicity because as a human
I have no expectation that changing the
subject from a plural pronoun to a
singular one or using a pronoun as
opposed to a full noun phrase like the
bakery would have any effect on the
interpretation of the adjective mean in
these cases and yet nonetheless the
model's predictions changed and that
manifest for me as a lack of
systematicity
and that's a kind of guiding intuition
behind many of the adversarial or
challenge data sets that people have
posed they have a hypothesis grounded in
the systematicity of language and they
observe departures from that in their
models and they begin to worry about
those models
it's interesting to reflect on the
compositionality principle in the
context of the history of AI models in
the earliest eras of AI like the shirt
loose system or the chat 80 system that
we saw on the first day we got kind of
compositionality by Design because those
were implemented grammar symbolic
grammars that themselves adhere to the
compositionality principle so we didn't
wonder about whether these nlu models
were compositional because we kind of
presupposed that they would be
and parts of that actually did carry
forward into the more modern machine
learning era for example many semantic
parsing systems like this one depicted
from Percy Leong's work were also
compositional in the sense that
underlyingly there was a compositional
grammar and the task was to learn
weights on the rules of that grammar and
so arguably the resulting artifacts were
compositional with some stochasticity
associated with them being probabilistic
models
and even in the more modern deep
learning era we again saw systems that
were arguably compositional this is from
the paper that launched the Stanford
sentiment Tree Bank it's a recursive
tree-structured neural network and it
abides by the compositionality principle
in the sense that all the nodes depicted
in these structures denote vectors and
there was a complicated deep learning
function that combined those vectors to
derive the meaning for their parent
nodes and it did that recursively until
we got a meaning for the entire sentence
so it's not symbolic in the way of these
older systems and in the way of much
work in linguistic semantics but it is
arguably a compositional system an
intriguing property of those deep
learning artifacts in fact
but we have it seems kind of moved away
from that perspective now we're
confronted all the time with these huge
typically Transformer based models where
everything is connected to everything
else and it is certainly clear that we
have no guarantees of compositionality
or systematicity built into these
networks and in fact in the earliest
days people often worried that even
though they were performing well they
were learning non-systematic Solutions
and that motivated a lot of challenge
testing for them
the question now is can we pose
behavioral tests that will truly assess
whether models like this which are hard
to understand analytically have found
systematic solutions to the language
problems that we pose if the answer is
no we should worry and if the answer is
yes it's an amazing discovery about why
these models perform so well and also
often an amazing discovery about the
power of data-driven learning alone to
deliver systematic solutions to language
problems so it's kind of an open
question but a tremendously exciting set
of questions to be exploring now as our
models are getting so good even at the
Hard behavioral tasks that we pose for
them